gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out the
group to be classy yeah or to just a big
old piece of trash I'm your host Dave
Foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at hoodies in the
new edition she was just out front
watching the school buses go by with the
kids in it okay throwing eggs at it nice
and what they did but they did something
to piss her off sure okay my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
international businessman but always the
king of the boardwalk baby give it up
for KJ Kevin James from what's up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure your rate of you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are cooking
and obviously the greatest website of
all time
www.patreon.com or you garbage gang
check it out it's a freaking party over
there yeah it is and having a nice quick
shout out to our producer X Jordan Air
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the t's and he dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody uh
what up boys how about that dude we got
the low-key drinking this dude
got the [__] kid in here what do you
mean former employer of mine I would not
ask him for a reference
a guy likes the sauce he made his own
Hooch I'll tell you I'm hurting bad but
it would have been the most garbage
thing ever to cancel so here the [__]
out of here
that's I buddy we need a guy cancel on
our podcast recently with a tummy ache
whoa use the word tummy I have a tummy
ache I was like what are you a
four-year-old who ate too much Taffy
yeah
a tummy yeah
it was not good that's very childish
yeah yeah no I I was hurting because of
course our friend Joe DeRosa I if I see
him I know I'm [__] it's like yeah you
just know the dude because what here's
his game how he gets you I haven't seen
you in a while and you're like all right
let's catch up because I do love him
uh-huh and then he's like shot you're
playing he goes you're playing MSG
theater November 4th we got to do a shot
throw plug by the way
holy [__] New York City man I thought I
was good but but no way DeRosa said the
date yeah
I ain't doing two but but he goes you're
playing MSG we got to do a shot and I'm
like oh so now I'm a dick if I he's like
the toast is for you you have to do the
shot with us so it's him and uh Steve
Byrne and another guy another guy who I
don't know but he's a comedy adjacent so
we're doing the shot and I'm like I
[__] so I'm like I really I'm already
pretty drunk and I have to wake up early
and he uh he goes [__] all right fine
three whiskey shots here and let's get a
Nancy boy here
you're pulling those and they're doing
this [__] [__] oh shoddy [__] I'm
like you're 46. I gotta stop doing it
also he was like nobody calls me a [__]
literally did the shot I thought it was
too old for peer pressure that's the
first shot I did with him then next
round it just turns into like you're
already drunk and he's like he's like oh
[__] you dude [__] you he used to throw
a birthday party every year on a Monday
night because he's a comic she'll come
if it's Monday you try to leave the
thing at midnight 2 A.M you get cursed
out sure as I'm walking out [__] you
piece of [__] I remember a birthday he
had thanks for coming yeah happy
birthday I remember reading a birthday
one year at the original Stand we were
just sitting outside the club and he's
sitting in a chair and he just starts
projectile vomiting
Sam don't leave yet this is the only way
you can leave it
actually I'm just watching Joe yeah
gotta get a pizza
no I was hurting dang we could be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guests back with us again today he is
one of the best and brightest stand-up
comedians today and as he showed me he's
going to be at the theater at Madison
Square Garden November 4th do yourself a
[__] favor give it up for samarella
summer the fall and winter tour is
hectic but good because he's good busy
is good it's good it's good but I'm
[__] I'm feeling it dude I mean every
every Instagram post of yours is 18 more
cities that's crazy it's hard to I mean
you see what happens and it's just like
she's in the Ukraine next week
give Funny Bone I'll be there
the Late Show could use a couple
I'll be uh man he really blew the roof
off that place I was thinking you
thinking uh in Ukraine people they're
like someone's like are people still
dating there I was like what did they
say meet me or where this coffee shop
used to be
like meet me for a walk through the Run
uh yeah man [__] no I'm I'm out there
you kind of have to be of course because
I don't know when this shit's gonna you
don't know what it's you don't know when
it's all gonna stop so you gotta do
everything you can I said that to some I
said to someone the other night I was
like yeah I don't know when it's gonna
go away he's like oh it'll go away I was
like you don't have to be that [__]
yeah you have to be that sure
I'm saying it like half fake yeah like I
was going to keep rolling trying to be
humble yeah ah it'll go away no Sinatra
fell off you think we're [__] gonna
be today no of course Sinatra hit alone
we're [__] it's over it's done I gotta
start singing
I did want to ask you about that good
with your travel and all that stuff I
did come across on Instagram uh I think
one of your uh stories I see you have
gotten to the point of success now where
you're traveling with the puppy dog with
you well that was traveling with the
pooch and that's the girl I'm dating dog
that's not even my dog I was very happy
to see that I love that dog 16 year old
one-eyed pug yeah dude I'll tell you the
sad [__] we were at the vet the other
day which is like I [__] have so much
respect for vets they're like you know
because they got into it because they
actually love animals so doctors don't
they're not doctors because they like
people yeah you know they're learning
for a check for the check yeah and uh
but it's like the funniest job to me
because you have to come in and deliver
horrible news with the funniest names
ever oh yeah like we found a malignant
tumor in waffles
Snuffaluffagus the cancer has spread
it's always so bad because I didn't
realize dude my wife pointed out to me
that she's like I hate going I'm like
why she's like because in the the
waiting room I've almost called it a
green room in the waiting room you're
sitting there with people on their worst
day of their decade they're like ready
to put their cat down or whatever and
I'm sitting there like who'd you Google
like I'm getting a checkup
meanwhile there are people crying I'm
like oh [__] this is tough yeah the
funniest parties were there and she's
got two dogs one of them's a a bigger
black pug and they put the uh they put
the thermometer you know the rectal
thermometer up the ass and she's like ah
ah just screaming you're like oh my God
that must suck then they put it in this
tiny little girlfriends right oh she
doesn't no I'm not I don't have that
effect no but she uh then they put it in
the tiny Pug's ass not a peep just like
this this pug lived in the street before
it's dark [__] he's like did you start
yeah hey Doc I don't have all day can't
do anything to me that La hasn't already
done fire away doc that's a good man
though you go to you go to the vet with
the with the ladies you did because the
dogs they're your dogs now no I mean
it's her dog I know but I love that yeah
I [__] love that dog you're in I mean
I hated her at first and then they just
win you over sure they do the dogs are
just incredible just positive energy at
all times they're just this dog's kind
of a [__] okay she's kind of rude she's
like but you know it's never picks up a
check
and the venmo request that's like come
on but she's just adorable I guess like
yeah she won me over what can I say
that's funny nice yeah I saw that I was
like oh Sammy traveling with the with
the puppy dog were you on your way to a
gig though no I was doing uh she as a
place in Texas and I was I did a couple
podcasts and all this I did nice Tom
Segura yeah very nice shout out to ymh
yeah it's so fun yeah yeah it's a blast
uh one thing too the travel for you has
upgraded
you got a tour bus we watch Foley would
love it because we're watching movies
you know that's the thing is like you're
dating a girl she's like are you [__]
someone on the road I'm like we're
literally drinking red wine yeah
watching Fargo I know yeah this is like
the lamest you think like you think
we're living hard and we're like the
[__] corniest dude I know yeah it's
not like I'm [__] it's not like we're
poison or something you know what I mean
they were so mad at me on the bus
because I I chose we you know we're on
the road all the time so you don't get
to see any of the Oscar movies so I was
like let's watch tar
the worst Tour Bus movie it's like a
slow burn about me too and I'm like I'm
sorry guys hey Gary I apologize
he would have rather me me too than
watch that movie no but then we usually
watch good [__] like we dude you know
what we watch in there this old movie uh
Fritz Lang made up in the 50s it's
called the big heat it's just like the
coolest old uh cop movie it's just an
unhinged cop whose wife gets murdered
and he's just like got nothing to lose
and he's just it's it's when you you
know like is this gonna be another
taller I'm like I've seen this one
no more tar is this the situation as of
right now on the tour you're on a bus no
I don't it's so expensive that I only do
it for you know it's got to make sense
like I got to be there the next night
and the next night and the next night
and then you gotta travel overnight when
it's like teleportation I mean Sammy
that's [__] that's big time it's
awesome yeah I love it if it makes sense
so we did it on three stretches we did
like a you know I dude I [__] love
the bus because you just wake up in the
city we did it with Bert and it was like
we went to bed in Vegas we leave at like
two or three in the morning wheels up on
the bus you hang out a couple beers go
to sleep you wake up here but it's like
you teleported we time it so you leave
like when we're trying to sleep because
it rocks you to bed like a pig it's like
being in a Millennium Falcon it's
[__] great one of the best night
sleeps I've ever had yeah you [__]
the blackout curtain comes all the way
up you got the little vent in there it
was fun for us because we're on the
we're on the bus with the big guy you
know he's like the daddy is that what he
feels [__] safe and secure yeah Bert
must be fun to tour with I've done a
couple gigs with bird and he's like man
it's funny his week like going light
with alcohol I was like wow I'm hurting
he would just like kill a pitcher beer
and he's like yeah I'm taking it easy
this week
bird is a it's incredible yeah I know he
goes he gets after it heavy for sure
which is and I've always wanted it was
always one he's always one of those guys
I'm like I have to have a beer with him
when I'm with them if he's like I'm
drinking like he came in here he makes
it look so good like when he has a beer
in front of him I saw him alcohol should
pay him money not like not like a brand
like all alcohol the lobby the alcohol
Lobby should get together and just cut
him a monthly check like a Native
American Casino he just gets ten percent
of everything the booze oligarchs should
be [__] paying well you see like a
dude in a [__] like an old movie
smoking a cigarette you're like [__]
Humphrey BOGO with this yeah and then
you're like oh [__] he died in his 50s
but in the movie like that looked
[__] cool now but Bert was in an
airport one time and he went up I guess
he was he was he got up to the bartender
he goes what's a good breakfast beer
to the to the to the bartender and I was
like man that makes you want to have a
[__] beer in the morning so [__]
bad but guess what cone it a breakfast
beer is not that doesn't make it that
sounds appetizing there is there is
breakfast beer too something fruity
something light maybe no that could be a
week beer that's what that is Cinnamon
Toast beer
no he's that's he goes hard it's
impressive I but I'll tell you hair the
dog I know it doesn't really work it
does but it's yeah it's like a mind game
where like something about like a Bloody
Mary on a flight you're like [__] that
help get me started yeah it hits right
those bloodies the guy likes a bloody
what do you have anything because
obviously it's like a shorter what is
the thing that you have to have on the
or that you found on the bus that you
really like like I like having this or
like is it what what same driver every
time yes he's the [__] coolest got
you this is how cool he is he's he's
seen so much [__] like by the way he
told us this is a great story he gave us
uh he used to take out Segura and you're
not supposed to poop on a tour bus okay
you know but uh because it just sits in
there yeah it's not it makes the whole
bus smell you pee and you pull over if
you have to poop but he goes yeah Tom
was just [__] in a glad bag for a
while and he was like what are you doing
and Tom's like oh yeah sorry like he
just didn't tell him he was [__] in
there that's crazy and uh yeah he's had
so many bands doing insane [__] he has
like Air Supply the week before me looks
better Air Supply you guys are watching
Tara
he's on the phone he's like yeah I got a
couple of [__] on here now babe you
guys don't want Coke or hookers or
anything like that well James we're in
the middle of Steel Man uh Webb uh who
he directed my last special he films on
the road and stuff and he's in there
he's got a big thing of creatine powder
because he works out like twice a day as
a machine and then we had a fake gun on
the bus as a joke it was just us being
stupid that's how you get arrested I
know oh dude we were filming we have a
bag of white powder and a real gun oh no
that looks real we're not smart Okay so
anyway he comes on and just sees this
giant bag of powder and a gun and goes
is that a real gun that's all it doesn't
give a [__] oh like like oh cool is that
a real gun and we're like no it's not
we're just [__] idiots we were
shooting a dumb promo with it it was
like John Morant was in the news so I
would I took a gun on morning uh okay
Memphis morning TV trying to be hit like
on on Zoom I didn't go in the studio
oh my God
what the [__] although my publicist was
like don't bring a gun in studio I'm
like how dumb do you think I am I don't
know that's a crossbow
I mean yeah yeah you got to give that if
you're even contemplating a gun as a bit
you gotta be like don't do that well
this is how dumb we are we I just said
how dumb you think I am Gary did run
through the stream with a gun you're
shooting the promo and we thought it was
funny and I'm like holy [__] we should
have been shot but uh yeah he just found
the gun and the creatine and was like is
this gun and Coke like and we're like no
it's not we're just idiots but you
didn't care oh my God I got my guy don't
worry he's that he's so cool that I
called a guy
in the audience slow one night I was
just like [__] on it for being dumb
and the next night he got me a propeller
hat as a joke oh no [__] because he's
like he's like this is a funny hat for
that bit and I was like it wasn't a bit
I was just calling a guy dumb but I was
like I love that this is where your
head's at yeah no he's the coolest I
like how you're the comic and you're
like well it wasn't a band
prop stuff you know you know working my
ass he was he's the best yeah two of us
like [__] rules I love it that's sick
that's the other thing it's like but
yeah you gotta gotta make a call what
kind of booze do you have do you have
any booze that you're like I want like
stocked on there my booze Bodega cat
whiskey shout out to what's on the set
we have that and we have all the mixers
right there I'll do a Manhattan on the
on the bus you know go do a little
vermouth bitters I even get the [__]
the Cherry the good Cherry I love it the
Brandy cherries yeah dude I love those
they're all right I love that and we'll
do some we'll do one we'll do that
sometimes I want sometimes I want a
Negroni too I like to get [__]
Negroni lit up everyone it's [__]
classy I love it I love it or I'll just
do I will do a scotch straight too I
love just like I just love you drink
like a jazz guy I know he does he's all
over the place man he's sitting here in
basketball shorts
what was the life expectancy on those
Jazz guys again not great not a good
ending huh yeah uh no Dave's level 28.
yeah I always think of that Miles Davis
quote uh man it takes you a long time to
sound like yourself isn't that the best
quote Oh that's good that's a [__]
great he's got a bunch of them yeah he's
got a bunch of them it's crazy to be
that good at jazz and also say really
interesting [__] yeah he has one of my
favorite uh song titles of all time the
one song uh it never even entered my
mind is the name of the song man it's a
[__] good one too just that lunch it
never even entered my mind
man I love uh Jon Stewart used to have a
joke where he would be like you know
black people and Jews are very similar
you know uh black people have the blues
and and Jews We complain we just never
thought to put it to music you know I
love that that's great yeah
some of John Stewart's old stand-up is
[__] funny let's go yes yeah it's
really yeah for a little while he was
like [__] high-end comic yeah no yeah
I mean before the show is the show the
tour I don't think but like but if he
did I think his stand-up would be killer
cooking yeah yeah one of those great
minds yeah home run okay let's talk
about Factor shout out to the fact tizor
big fans of the factor over here gang a
lot of things going on this fall season
you got to pick the kids up at soccer
practice you got to take the dog to the
vet here this that the other thing a lot
of times you don't have time to cook
dinner let Factor take care of it send
it right to your door have them ready in
two minutes they're absolutely fantastic
yeah guys it's great like I've said I've
been using it for years before they were
a sponsor I found them they were
fantastic I used them for a year and a
half two years then they came on as a
sponsor now we got the whole crew on
them T-Bone Foley me chicken marsala I'm
gonna shredded chicken taco bowl man if
they could send me 15 15 of them a week
I'd be all with the mash rice and the
mushrooms yeah fantastic takes two
seconds I throw it on you can throw it
in a microwave I do it on a skillet it's
easy peasy so head to factormeals.com
garbage50 and use code garbage 50 to get
50 off baby that's five zero that's code
garbage five zero at factormeals.com
garbage five zero to get 50 off it's a
party over there they got tons of
different things dietitians doing if
you're doing keto if you're doing Locale
whatever you want they'll take care of
you that's factormeels.com garbage five
zero to get 50 off do it yeah okay let's
talk about Harry's shout out to Harry
shout out to Harry's I'll tell you that
right now the best subscriptions are
things you need regularly but you always
forget to buy it to the last minute and
it runs out Harry's make sure you always
have a clean shave by keeping you
stocked with razors and all your shaving
Essentials schedule refill deliveries
for as low as two bucks two beans two
dollars making it easy peasy for you to
keep your shaver Dean and to keep it
budget friendly yeah these are uh these
razors stay seriously sharp that your
eighth shave is just smooth as your
first I use it on my little nether
regions for a tight squeeze baby it's
fantastic just join the core not any
subscription subscription everybody's
doing subscription Harry's is a proper
subscription they send it right to your
door it's razors are the things you
forget about till you go to shower like
I'm jumping in I got a hot date with a
guy a gal whatever you go to shave and
you get your dull old razor there not
with them the way the handle gives you
precise controls no matter what you're
looking look you're going for Harry's
has you covered uh they have the highest
customer satisfaction in the Shaving
industry their no risk trial means that
if you're not 100 satisfied no worries
your shave is on them get a subscription
that saves you time and money with
Harry's get started with a 13 starter
set for just three bucks at harrys.com
garbages harrys.com garbage for the
three dollar Starter Set do it
all right but let's get into some cues
with the same questions guys as you know
when you're doing a patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
uh it's just the best way to do it the
patreons get first crack at it uh this
one's from Taylor Chris new ten dollar
homie here yeah there you go is it
garbage to buy a shirt for a video job
interview and return it because you
didn't get the job
which I didn't think of it's a video job
you don't have to you just do shirt up
so he just went out and bought a nice
button-up shirt I presume left the tag
on which you can't tell no
all right you're saving money on the
pants exactly sitting there in
basketball shorts having a Manhattan I
think you should have one nice shirt
though I do agree yeah especially if
you're in a job he's unemployed Sammy
against the job yeah I did a gig uh
Hassan got me this gig for Giannis
antetokumpo's benefit that you know the
basketball player and that stavros's
favorite basketball yeah so I'm like
dude come with me great and and it's at
the rainbow room and stuff's like I
don't have nice clothes and I was like
you're a millionaire and you don't you
don't have one nice article of clothing
I'm wearing the [__] shirt right now
yeah but he goes uh yeah I don't and
he's like can I wear a sweatsuit I was
like to the rainbow room I don't I mean
I guess and he was like no I don't want
him I was like dude I want you there but
he was like he just bought a suit like a
week ago that's awesome well we were
just talking to Sal vulcano about it as
well he's like I'm done with suits
you're getting cat jeans khakis whatever
and I'm like I guess you get to a point
your lights are cool though suits are
cool suits are cool but as a as bigger
gentlemen this is yeah you look good
these suits are cool on you yeah you
look good I never wear them though you
could get like a nice five thousand
dollar suit and look [__] I'm not
spending that much
five thousand dollars what am I gonna
get four thousand dollars three thousand
dollars for a suit uh but I'm saying you
could you know you got the frame to pull
it off yeah they don't look good after
time I look like a fat kid at a wedding
yeah
I think you should have one I mean I
understand like yeah sure return it but
you should have one nice shirt no that
makes sense especially if you are on the
searching for jobs like he's gonna need
it in a week or something if he gets
another [__] interview
I didn't think about that yeah what
about the next have a little faith in
yourself but I think I think returning
is fine people return everything I mean
like I I think I feel like women do that
[__] constant they do book and I never
have I've maybe even said I'm going to
take this back but then I get [__]
ketchup or something on it now I don't
know if I've ever returned clothes in my
life if I've ever brought a lazy dude
yeah of course yeah I'm not bringing it
back it is what it is I already paid for
it I've already turned a Blazer once and
I regret it every day since why because
it was a really cool [__] loud red
blazer and it was like it was weird and
I you know Ryan Hamilton yeah of course
he's like my go-to for like fashion very
sharp guys looks good he dresses very
well he's like a low-key he he dresses
well where you like don't notice he's
dressing and I'll be like that guy looks
good so I text him and he go I go what
do you think of this Blazer and he goes
uh this is polite way of saying I look
like [__] you might have to change your
personality a bit for that Blazer and I
was like okay I'm [__] returning it
Jesus Christ like as if I need to have
more energy and I was like I regret it
so much I love that did you ever gonna
wear it I'll send you the Blazer and you
could plug it in here I think it looks
no I [__] took it home tried it on
send them the pick and then he goes
basically told me I look like [__] and I
I returned it yeah I know I regret it
every day since because they were it was
so I went back to get it it was sold out
is it before did would you have had to
have it tailored at all like were the
sleeves long or I think it was perfect
it was perfect
it was meant to be and I was a coward I
would like Blazers to really come a nice
Blazer yeah would be I have that with
bombers I mean there's like casual
jackets are a thing nah but it's not
like we were you were saying uh and
we've talked about this but when you get
to a certain stage of success or wealth
you can stop wearing the you know the
straight suit like when Seinfeld rolls
around the jeans and the Blazers the
jeans and the blaze but a pair of Nikes
he looks [__] but it's so it's so
funny because I think you dress like the
style of when you blew up because like
she's because he's wearing that outfit
but then it's like Nike Shox and you're
like
I mean when you're that rich it doesn't
have to take that much effort sure but
like he does I think he looks pretty
Sleek no you put Jerry in a suit yeah
about it it's over his hair's longer now
too he looks incredible he looks better
than he did incredible ten years ago or
whatever yeah cause the because the
style in the 90s like all the Seinfeld
people are like you know like Jerry is
like not a bad looking guy but the hair
is rough on that show same with Elaine
Elaine is insanely hot but I would
rather [__] Veep Julia Louis-Dreyfus
than Seinfeld she changed she changed
when she had the poof the season two
hair yeah she changed it and when she
started working for Peterman as it
started getting tightened it up yeah
it's got a little bit of cash
Peterman was [__] hot yeah have you
seen that that guy's like gorgeous yeah
he's great and he's got a great voice oh
yeah he does a lot of radio uh yeah like
for like radio stations like you're
tuned into B101 or whatever but in the
80s and and the very early 90s and the
70s too they could only have gotten away
with those hairstyles then like Jerry's
hair in the show was like it didn't look
like there was any product in it it's
just that's how it grew like into that
kind of mullet kind of thing you know
what I mean my uncles had those at the
time yeah like now you would never you
would have something in your hair yeah
it's like the 86 Mets haircut yes oh
yeah the key that's what it is
Gary Carter they all had hair like they
did it was like long curly hair yeah and
that [__] and then you even have the
dudes like Kelsey Grammer who like went
ball and they're like I'm Gonna Keep the
back keep the bag like you have a curly
mullet dude yeah I was talking but
you're like dignified it made it work
look better as when he did cut it though
on free or on Cheers he had it right
yeah and then when he was on Frasier he
was clean cut good looking he shortened
it up a little bit Yeah Yeah
Frasier [__] rules dude that was a
sleeper I didn't watch it when it was on
it was just like too smart for my dumb
family I guess it was like what do you
know nobody would we wouldn't watch that
they're all like bricklayers and stuff
but then I watched it I think on Netflix
like five years ago for the first time
and I was like this is so [__] funny
it's funny because what you're raising
but you realize about the character and
even on Cheers too as educated and
formal as he was he was a scumbag at
heart he really he was always trying to
get one oh he get caught in a lie he had
to keep it moving oh yeah yeah it was
always pulling trying to pull the wool
over someone's eyes he's always trying
to get laid yeah
dude I mean that was his line I'm
listening that's a dude who's trying to
get laid I loved it yeah keep the shirt
dude you should have kept the shirt back
to the point he's talking about Reese
all right holy [__] you're a real Pro
uh all right let's see this one's in the
same uh this one is fashion as well this
is from NED giganski shout out to you
shout out is it garbage for your entire
wardrobe to be Amazon essentials which
I've never really dabbled on the
essentials clothing I don't know what
that is so they have their own brand
they have cheap like Kirkland signatures
yeah yes which I love Yeah Amazon
essentials is pretty good for everything
like all stuff like kitchen stuff or
whatever can all be Amazon essentials
you can just get cheap [__] on Amazon
like everything that's like seven bucks
is Amazon essential because you get a
bunch of shirts that shirt that Gillis
the first shirt Gillis wore on oh the
blue Rogan the blue like golf polo was
uh Amazon essentials he sold a couple of
those things yeah they ran him out of
stock that could move tickets there you
go
um okay so that's but I haven't crossed
the bridge into Amazon clothes have you
I think I got a shirt once like I I
think I have like a white button down
okay uh from that but yeah no I don't
really you spend money on clothes yeah
where are you going close shots uh
geez I don't no not crazy what are your
jeans let's start there jeans the jeans
I actually wore last night are free I
got them from uh doer who's a sponsor of
our podcast so I wear those I'll go like
Nordstrom Rack sometimes like not doers
like the whiskey or no how [__] funny
you're such a booze bag that's literally
I was like damn he's got [__] whiskey
jeans yeah this shirt is Makers Mark and
uh yeah no uh so it was that I'll get
jeans and Nordstrom reaction but I don't
really shop a ton but like because I
don't like shopping but like I'll get
like a nice jacket for uh like a special
or like okay uh the thing you do once
everything but the worst part is I feel
like I can't wear it again because it's
just people like oh that's his only Jack
and I just saw a special so uh no I'll
get I'll go like I'll get like cool
jackets sometimes but I yeah I don't I
don't spend a ton of money on clothes as
a New York guy and we're talking about
this time of the year I'm sure you like
a nice uh a nice light light jacket for
the fall I love Yeah occasionally I went
to uh I produce Gary veter special which
is going to come out in like December or
something and I got I made him wear a
suit so I got him a suit because I was
like I want him to wear a suit uh
because he's all one liner so I was like
you should wear it's very old it's like
at a place in time almost and he was
like all right so then I was there we're
at suit supply and I was like I'm gonna
get some [__] cool super supplies got
some good stuff and it's relatively
affordable it's pretty inexpensive
that's what I want I want a deal dude
yeah he likes a deal I I really feel
weird about paying full price for [__]
do you remember Mo ginsburg's in New
York back in the day no it was it was I
remember the ads yeah it was about
Ginsburg Mo Ginsburg you would go there
you'd get like four suits for one it was
like a Men's Warehouse thing yeah my
grandpa Joseph A Bank my grandpa was
high up at lowman's do you remember no
so I know the name it was like an outlet
store it was like cheap affordable
clothing with designers and he was like
a big dude over there so we would go
there and that was all our shopping and
my mom got a discount so it was already
like marked down three times and then my
mom took out like a lowman's card and
then we knocked off like another 25 so
I'm like did I just get a blazer for
three dollars
you owe us yeah here's your six dollars
yeah Romans was [__] cool they but
they they went they went down yeah what
was your back to school shopping when
you when you were a kid what would that
like well I went through I went to an
all-boy School in the city so it was
like uniforms yeah I had to wear a
blazer and uh yeah so it was just like I
had like one Blazer I wore every [__]
day where'd you go Browning in Midtown
did yeah did we know that probably
that's on the first episode that's up
there that's like that's like a spence
yes yes and uh yeah Blazer tie and I
hated it it's it's it made me it's like
having too much sugary cereal as a kid
you [__] don't want to dress up sure
that makes sense you know yeah but uh
that makes sense I like seeing those
kids running around the city though
after school they look like businesses
that's hilarious a bunch of little
accountants running around I used to
have a friend who would do a joke about
it like the kid with the Rollie bag and
he's like oh [__] I got a spelling bee
in Chicago you know you're like it's a
good bit yeah he doesn't do comedy
anymore is this guy named Mike barish
[Laughter]
yeah
cut that out
and get me a roller bag that's always
weird to me the guys who just like have
hilarious [__] and they just got there
was this guy I knew early on named Glenn
Coyle and he was like one of the first
Comics ever met he died he was really
funny he was always just like seemed
like the worst habits always always
pounding booze always gambling like
every bad advice he had sounds like
someone I know
I call him a rose [__] when he dies I
can't even hear him over is Elizabeth be
a great auction man let's just watch him
in heaven who wants his airplane trunk
us seven dollars that was a good bid
what the hell yeah uh but he had a bit I
loved where he goes uh he goes uh my
girlfriend got Lou gehrer's [__] I
[__] it up my girlfriend got Lou
Gehrig's disease so I traded her
that's a great [__] thing a good
smart bit yeah uh that reminded the
auction it off reminds me of it was
something similar that I think in
Seinfeld I'm Telling him for the last
time when he's putting to bet he's put
into bed all that material and it's all
he they literally have it's like Robert
Klein all those people
um I'm drawing blanks and all their
names now but they have it in Italian
everybody's there Paul Reiser George
Wallace yes and they have all the
material in a coffin and like if he's
put it to bet like he's you know he's
burying it for the last time and like
shamling or somebody or Robert Klein
walks up and like grab and like he's
like saying goodbye like you would a
body like I missed you so much but he's
writing down bits that he sees in that
[__] goal he's like you're not gonna
use it that's uh man that's such a great
game yeah it was great damn he uh did
you ever get any clothes from anybody
when they died
like when he had a second uncle or
something oh actually yeah my grandpa
yeah he was like very and it's funny but
he was like he like left me close but he
was like his name his initial to be
monogrammed on I'm like you think I want
to wear like Jay
gjg shirts it was like are they outside
or the inside on the outside oh like it
was like a collared shirts and he was
like my initials on all of them and I'm
like I can't wear yeah it's a little
weird it's a little weird but spin it is
a new Cool brand the gesture was very
sweet but yeah I can't wear this [__]
yeah I got all my uncles old suits when
he when he passed but he took everything
with triple starch like they would like
literally cut your neck like the shirts
were just so sharp all Joseph A Bank
suits and there was a time when he would
show up somewhere I just wore them in
all like he got all of these like nicer
clothes that he doesn't have anywhere to
wear them so he would show up to like
the Village Lantern in a trench coat and
be like what are you doing dude oh my
God you're here to bark man he's got a
briefcase since I'm like what are you
doing yeah it was weird I remember
barking and they're like man you really
wear you gotta dress you don't want to
be like the well-dressed beggar sure yes
you know what I mean I remember I hated
barking so much like the pity people
would give you with I remember hand down
flyers on like Upper West Side it was
like a hundred and
seventh it was 107th and West End it was
a place called The Underground lounge
and the worst is like I didn't mind
handing out flyers in Times Square
because you get a million people walking
yeah you're distracted upper west side
it's like two people every three minutes
so you're just like bored out of your
[__] mind but I remember a woman just
walked right up to me and she went oh it
[__] broke I was like this is or you
then you get the people in your show and
your bomb well you're like oh my God so
many big names in the show tonight and
then they it's like four people in the
crowd and then you go up and they're
like what the [__] yeah you're not a
great guy yeah
yeah a lot of great guys Sam Morel is
here they're like oh having her he's
very good you should young kid real good
dance danger main he was barking and he
this was the most self-loathing thing
I've ever seen a person do he handed out
flyers for an hour and a half for stage
time and uh he goes I'm gonna leave and
the guy was like you only have to do 10
more minutes and he goes nah I'm good he
just did an hour and a half for no
reason I was like this dude's sick she's
a sick [__] I did that catty at one time
I only had like two holes to go and I
was like yeah I'm getting out of here I
can't do it anymore buddy you're on your
own
when in doubt use the three iron eyes
I've definitely quit jobs like to quit
jobs like that I'd go to the the
bathroom or lunch and just be like I'm
not going back oh and then just walk
straight out it feels good yeah as
Costanza said the water feels great that
the fact that that's in a real story is
the craziest [__] on SNL right walked
out and and quit and then just showed
back up I was joking it's great what an
insane you thought that was real yeah I
did all the time
I mean to be to throw away that kind of
money at that point of your career oh
yeah writers or SNL but I also I get it
his brain is like too neurotic and not
in a bad way it's just too like hyper it
was like I don't want this sucks like he
focuses on the negative I don't think I
knew that was from SNL that's what he
did what he's positive it is Jesus did
you get the job back I think so no [__]
I think a comedy writer they flipped him
a Mickey it's a good thing to do but
yeah he was to he couldn't be confined
to that type of like his he needs to go
crazy that's why curb is like perfect
for him right he needs a rated our
environment we'll just say whatever the
[__] he wants and do whatever he wants
yeah he's not a big rule follower
another he's not making the rules bald
with the with the long hair in the back
that's true rocks it also but Seasons
when it was Tighter and like crisper a
little bit not so it works on him though
works great is he zany yeah yeah it
works great it's a funny look it's a
good comedic look yes it's not trying to
be cool that is a thing too of like you
know you're trying to buy nice clothes
it's so
anti-comedy as a whole it's so anti-cool
isn't that true you're like I can't but
like I would like to be like I'd like to
wear that jacket but I could not walk up
and be like what's up everybody like you
can't be cool and also do comedy we're
not supposed to be winners that's the
thing so it's inherently it's weird to
to be but then also you're like playing
these bigger venues and you don't want
to look like you don't give a [__] about
the crowd it's this weird contradiction
where you're like I need to look like I
care but also like it's so I think that
this thing is to just wear [__] that
fits I think that's it yeah because a
lot of a lot of dudes I say that as I'm
wearing a [__] oversized shirt and
[__] shorts that are too short uh
guys all over the road you do a real
racquetball vibe
a tournament
have you played pickleball no and I
won't I don't I get that it's fun it's
[__] it's tennis right no no it's
like Ping Pong meets tennis yeah all
right it's real shorter but you're
hitting the ball over a net yeah it's
pretty fun that's like a rubber ball no
it's like a wiffle ball so it doesn't go
that fast so it's like you know older
people okay I don't know I feel like
that it was so popular tennis is so
[__] popular right now yeah it's
crazy it's I was watching some of it and
holy [__] it's like it's amazing US Open
was all right it was it's no I'm
surprised you would you you wouldn't
know I've never been to one I'd love to
uh but man uh
this [__] it's so funny that Russian
dude just gets booed for being Russian
and he's so mevidev but he's so [__]
funny yeah Russians are so dark and
funny oh yeah they're just they're just
like Boo and he's just like yeah you
think that's the worst part of his year
okay
now his life is probably now it's good
but or that he's the one pulling the
strings over there it's like I don't
even own a drone what the [__] you want
from me the [__] out of my family I
wasn't advising Putin on this one uh
yeah crazy I said stay relax uh all
right let's see this one's from K uh ten
dollar loaner new homie uh is it garbage
to save podcast episodes to burn on a CD
for your car because your phone is
broken damn that's crazy people but I
still got burners like that probably you
can burn every computer can probably
have the capability I guess there's no
CD not anymore a disc in this thing yeah
no I know that's an option you need to
get an adapter there's one on that
though there's probably no CD drive on
that there sure isn't that oh [__] that
is a very expensive computer really damn
I I don't know that makes sense yeah
that's like having a printing press you
got [__] ripped off there's no CD
burner or anything that's your computer
that's our computer God we got ripped
off it's not it's not as bad as like
burning it on like a mini disc but it's
not far off it's not good Minnie just
never got steam they were cool for like
a year not even that I think I know what
you're talking about there was a CD
inside of them yeah it looked like that
yeah it was like the clear disc I just
don't yeah I mean it's funny I don't
someone I had Stavros gifted me DVDs on
my birthday because he's like just these
are movies I know you love so he like
got me criteria and I was like I don't
have a DVD player you don't I figured
you would still have a DVD player and
some DVDs on display I don't I just
stream right yeah you can get everything
online at this point I shouldn't yeah I
should get one I don't know maybe I'll
get one after I know the Roses still has
a pretty strong DVD collection yeah Joey
roses he likes that stuff though he's in
like the you know the video games and
stuff yeah he's uh the tangibleness he
is yes okay let's talk about beam shout
out beam me up baby and let's go gang we
know that the best thing you could do
for yourself is to get a good night's
sleepover not getting a good night's
sleep you're gonna be jammed up that can
be associated with weight gain it could
be associated with uh slow like white
blood cell count and in mental health
poor mental health no bueno I gotta get
you some beam over there get yourself a
good night's sleep if you're sick you
counting cheap it's time to try beam
healthy hot cocoa for sleep yeah it's
fantastic they sent it to us two
packages uh you mix it up uh the other
night put me night night hot water or
milk you stare at your froth it enjoy
before your bedtime it's all right and
today our listeners get a special
discount on beams dream powder baby
there you go They're best selling
healthy hot cocoa for sleep with no
added sugar now valve on delicious
flavors like sea salt caramels my
favorite cinnamon cocoa hot chocolate
peanut butter better sleep has never
tasted better a recent clinical study
revealed dream helped 93 of users wake
up feeling more refreshed and 93
reported that dream helped them get a
more restful night's sleep it's in the
numbers if you want to try beam's
best-selling dream powder get up to 40
off for a limited time when you go to
shopbeam.com garbage and use the code
garbage to check out that's beam I'm
sorry that shot beam
[Music]
b-e-a-m.com slash garbage use the code
garbage to get up to 40 off do it gang
that it's weird that kind of makes you
like being a collector of vintage [__]
it's like what's the line between being
a collector and just like a [__]
hipster
it's a very fine whether or not you're a
dick about it sure yeah if you've got an
attitude he does it cool he collects
cool stuff yeah I guess he also dresses
pretty well too he dresses cooler for a
comic yeah it's a little punk rock he's
got if you ever look he'll show up in a
cool t-shirt and a real nice bomber
or like a laser cool a different a pair
of pants I couldn't pull off yeah yeah
it wasn't when we saw him at Chrissy D
was it Chrissy D he had like a pair of
quarter Rollies on or something like
that that were real sharp like you're
praising him
yeah those and there's
one we're missing the hole
yeah Sharpay
hey now he uh yeah I guess he does he
does he's got a bit of a flare not a
normal I mean like we're all just
he's not a standard like blue jeans on
black t-shirts comedians are scared to
take any fashion risks because you're
gonna get crazy oh my God anytime I put
something on I just I hear Keith
Robertson's voice oh you were the worst
how dare you you get a [__] haircut
comedian [__] on yeah you do anything
that's different than how you are it's
like by the way the same comedian who is
like we need to accept trans people then
that you show up with a slightly
different haircut they're like you
[__] [__] yeah
whatever happened to that acceptance I
remember we were barking down in the
village years ago and uh we were like
trying we were trying to get to the
point where it's like okay you know we
don't want it we want to try to maybe
move out of open mics you want to try to
do some produce shows more like car
shows so you know how there's like that
those those steps of like all right try
to be a little more presentable you know
what I mean don't look like a dirt bag
or whatever let me bomb in a collared
shirt yeah
and Reggie Conquest man showed up in
this [__] short sleeve button-down
floral print and he got out of the cab
across the street and just the [__]
laser dots all over them there was like
15 of us on the corner and he knew he
was walking into a [__] beating dude
and we were we were on the [__]
hanging on a [__] mailbox just like
dirt balls like look at this guy in the
[__] shirt yeah it's tough yeah you
always have to have a tough look I'll go
shopping like with my wife if we're like
somewhere and we're like and she's like
oh this would be great I'm like that
would be great and I do kind of look
good in it and I it is nice I go but
there is nowhere for me to wear this I
do it a live show maybe nah some of the
stuff it's uh you know I I just I'm like
I don't feel comfortable in it there's
well I'm not wearing it on stage if I
don't feel kind I made the mistake on
our podcast it was the winter and Uniqlo
has that great heat tech stuff for the
winter so it keeps it's like you can
layer up you stay warm but I got one
they were out of I just wanted black but
they were out of black so I got it was a
turtleneck and I showed up and Norman
goes what is this your one-man show
I'm just getting killed for it the whole
episode and I [__] deserved it I mean
I looked I looked ridiculous yeah it was
it was a bad but it's like guess what
man those turtlenecks they keep you warm
but you can't dress for Comfort if
you're a comedian you got to be careful
yeah yes that's the problem too or
Comfort to a degree sure no it was uh
any outfit I remember I was at the comic
strip starting out and this owner Bob
wax who passed away but he was like very
much about like you know it was owned by
Richie who was like the blue collar
Bronx guy and Bob who was like the Upper
East Side like you should be presentable
and I remember he pulled me aside like
you need to dress better on stage he
really like shooting me out for in front
of a lot of people because I dress like
[__] and uh he goes I want to see you in
a polo shirt and I was like hungry to
get States I'm like [__] I'll do
whatever it takes to get stationed I
showed up in a polo shirt and I just got
crushed by every every Comics like you
[__] listen to him he's the [__]
bad guy yeah he's the guy you don't
listen and I yeah I got killed I
deserved it it's tough man that's
awesome though I never have more anxiety
now it's obviously I you know I have a
bit of a set costume or you know
wardrobe black T-shirt jeans I have
stuff I wear on the road like I don't
need live shows but then you feel like
you're copping Louie because that like I
feel like Louie like that outfit is like
the Louie classic I wear a watch because
of Louie really yeah 100 why is that I
don't know he always looks his watches
always look great he's got a nice watch
that's a nice watch thank you that's not
literally fishing for compliments he
just got it he's gonna watch Sam no but
that's what that's why I wear a watch
like this because I like the way it
looks on Louie's arm you watched the you
speaking of the US Open by the way do
you see the watches of this thing the
the tennis player finishes the match
runs to the locker room like puts on a
watch it's always been a big watch sport
it's a watch yeah Rolex sponsors yeah
yeah but it's like man it does I I'm
with you a nice watch looks nice nice
watch guy yeah I have one yeah yeah nice
watching a decent pair of sneakers yeah
I think I think it's always the way to
go I I I'm making a show business I
thought it was so stupid for the longest
time but what the reason I like a nice
watch is you can dress like [__] and
still look like you kind of care it puts
a little more
talking about this I have I wear at
weddings or if I'm going out like with
my like whatever that's the only time I
wear it is to like if you have a suit on
it just looks that much nicer and I like
knowing the time without having another
reason to look at my phone oh mine are
all wrong yeah up until I was wearing
another one it was broken for like four
years but I looked nice how about people
that wear the Apple watch I'm like you
need to another place text messages it's
just like that's that's that was like
you need an escape from the phone I
don't like it I've seen people on comics
on stage with the mic and then they're
like yeah so and you're like what are
you you you're you're it's a 15-minute
set you're not taping you're like what
are you doing 15 minutes oh no no on my
phone yeah no I'm trying new stuff oh
yeah no they're like no they're not
looking at notes they're like someone
emailed them and they're like clearing
up they're not reading it but they're
like clearing things up and I'm like
what is this no that's horrible you
could shut it down for 15 you look at
your phone for notes of course sure I'd
do it every time but that's crazy 15
minutes it's it feels Ruder than the
phone because at least the phone you're
like I'm sorry just giving them it but
but this they try to sneak it in yeah my
mom does it my mom's [__] did my mom
last night she's like ignoring me
looking at texts on her phone
I gotta be honest the conversation was a
little like I'm bored my you know my mom
did the other thing that really [__]
pissed me off I uh I'm you know at this
travel we get to lay like eight hours I
have an eight hour delay I'm so angry
and my mom and my mom I said Mom she's
like how are you [__] eight hour
delay I'm losing my mind she just goes
well they're having a hard time I'm like
the airlines you're my mom you're
shining us
[Laughter]
I don't think they are struggling I
think they get bailed out every few
years and they're doing quite well damn
when you guys go to dinner who who's
picking up that check
I usually usually them but I yeah yeah
but if it's like if it's like Father's
Day or like you know like a birth
obviously I pay but okay yeah nice yeah
how about you
um I'm trying to more and more I'm no I
gotta do better I'm gonna I'm at the age
I really should be at this point my
brother boss I know yeah I know you're
gonna pick up some chicken fingers my
parents ain't eating chicken fingers my
parents are in their 70s and in very
good health like yeah yeah like very
both very lean very uh do they like a
nice dinner too yeah my dad is like the
healthiest man I've ever met he's like
literally you would not think he's my
fault like who doesn't really drink ever
he'll have like an order of salmon and
take like two bites and be like I'm good
I'm like this is like weird yeah what
are you doing no kidding because you're
an eater you go I see though you go out
on the road you go nice restaurants
Gary veter opens and he wants he's such
a food [__] I mean he's like every city
he's like you better take me out fancy
tonight like I've never dated a woman
who talks like this but Gary's like I
want five stars [__] take my dog to the
vet we're in a group threat and it's
always like I found a restaurant tonight
and it's gonna cost you it's funny yeah
he got I got so sick in Arizona
um I was like very sick last time I
played stand up live and all Gary talked
about the whole way was Pizzeria Bianco
I want to go to Pizzeria Bianco and I
was so sick I could I mean luckily I'm a
low energy act so I can just do the set
just get me out there I'll be all right
but dude I'm I'm down in NyQuil and I
pass out in between sets I'm like that
that sick and uh and all on the dice
NyQuil or DayQuil oh I yeah I'm NyQuil
I'm trying to yeah cause I want to pass
out right after the set so I'm I'm dying
and then Gary as I'm this sick on the
couch goes you promised Pizzeria Bianca
but you promised me a better meal he's
such a [__] prick not but I love him
I do love them have you had any
restaurants stay open late for you any
like the tour manager ever line that up
of like hey we have Mr Morel in town he
takes swings I don't think nobody bites
I think yeah I think it has happened but
like I don't I don't uh no I mean I
remember opening for Z's back in the day
I'm sure he's got the rep of being a
foodie too yeah so they really wanted to
impress him uh that's got to be a good
feeling man yeah it was it was he eats
very well and then uh yeah Schumer glad
with Schumer sure it was really good
food back room private dining kind of
situation uh no she would eat like just
with everybody with the riffraff yeah
yeah
um she is like a [__] awesome Palette
too she used to take us out to uh like
big comic dinners at Keane's Steakhouse
which is hard to beat Kings man just
like the vibe the food uh but yeah we I
mean look we eat well because Gary will
like pick but it's not about the like
nicest it's about just like what's the
coolest like you you find these like
little little spots these little dude
I'll tell you like you get surprised
we're in Milwaukee we got Serbian food
I'm like this is like the one of the
best meals in my life really yeah no it
just every city has this like awesome
food culture now it's crazy yeah it's
true that is true you get anything
anywhere and it's like stuff that you're
like I don't know what Serbian food is
I'm like I'm assuming it's like maybe
like kind of similar to Middle Eastern
type food I don't know a Greek food it's
mostly shoes
picture a goat sandwich yeah but dude
it's like quality shoes it's like I was
eating I was like this is good leather
this is like Red Wings and um
uh the meat pie and [__] like that it's
like crazy good damn yeah you go to
Green Point man you get some Polish food
blow your brains I love that [__] Green
Point is like underrated it's still such
a cool it's a very cool it is I'm not
untouched but it's it's they're
developing it a lot more now but it
still has that Eastern European culture
like the Polish culture to it Hometown
oh they're touched they've been touched
sure sure a couple of condos like one of
Spacey's boys they've been touched but
still that street whatever that street
is it's [__] awesome Yes all the
little shops and stuff yeah uh great
Colin Quinn joke I think it was in a New
York I don't even know where I heard it
but he's like green point is
the such a perfect place for a Polish
neighborhood because it's you can see
Manhattan but it takes four hours to get
there oh he's like only because he's
like it was like a like you know a
[__] really smart Pollock joke Colin
Quinn's New York story is like maybe so
good it's like it's bad for me that that
bit about how uh how it's a walking city
in New York and like you know drivers
you know like oh my God I almost got hit
by that person you know like that's a
walking City his observations are just
so like the observation about your uh
you're in line to get food in any other
city it's polite to be like hello how
are you but in New York that's rude yeah
you're holding up it's like just amazing
observations that and Crossing uh if
you're on the express train is very New
York but if you're on the express train
and the local trains across the platform
hey you you want the doors to close
quicker so they can't get on the express
train you're like hurry up hurry up
everything that's such it's all and he
goes you see them walking over like
you mouth breather I don't want you on
my train it's very like yeah or the uh
like how the we're just quoting clowns
but they're the best bits and he had a
thing about uh how the element used to
be like you know all black and he's like
you get on the Williamsburg L train now
it's like a [__] ski lift you know
it's like oh my God it's like just all
about the perfect words yeah I imagine
somebody getting out of jail that went
in the jail in the into jail in the 80s
and gets out now and they get on the L
train it's like all right we're going
back to Brooklyn it's all white girls
with iPad
he gives me movie wrecks Colin Quinn
because he's seen every movie he's just
one of those dudes I saw him on like the
Criterion closet on YouTube and I was
like holy [__] Conklin's he's talking
about like these weird foreign films and
this guy's just knows everything he just
knows everything yeah so I'll hit him up
with movies and then occasionally I'll
throw in and I wrecked this movie to him
once and he was so angry at me I wrecked
this old it was like a old movie called
Mikey and Nikki with Peter Falk and John
cassavetes and I just saw it randomly
and it's slow but it's a [__] great
movie and uh and he's texting me 25
minutes in and goes [__] you I hate this
movie this movie stinks and I was like
oh my God I was like so panicked they're
like an hour and a half later he texts
me goes okay it was good it got there
yeah nice I only met him once or twice
waited on him back in the day in the
West Village really CQ small light lunch
cup of tea hit me with a 50. he's a
known we want to have him on the show
he's a known baby you haven't had him on
here yeah I would love that he would do
this yeah
yeah what happened this was the process
of getting Colin Quinn on our show uh
he his manager texts me uh Colin wants
to do your podcast and I just I was like
no he doesn't I know he doesn't want you
to know him I know you're trying to get
him on but I know he doesn't want to do
it I know Colin and then uh I ran into
Colin on the street like a day after and
I was like hey man do you want to do it
like obviously we want to have you on
but I thought you hate doing podcasts
and he goes no [__] your podcast I don't
want to do your podcast and then I get a
text from his manager later that day
Colin has agreed to do your podcast this
is the process for booking him right and
then we got him Joe's Pizza too because
I know I gotta put him in a good mood if
he's going to come in yeah what is it
I'm speaking to Joe's what's your
favorite New York slice you might have
done this on your last episode I like I
mean I'd say the one I go to the most is
Joe's I love a joke just because it's
like open late it's something about that
smell it's availability consistency
location it's it's such a not it's a
really good but it's like a just the
it's like a knock around so you can
always pop in and get a good slide but
for Vibe if I'm sitting down and eating
pizza
I love John's Yeah but I the one I go to
the most is Arturo's I would say no
kidding because on Houston because uh
right on the corner there yeah one of
the first co-loving places uh just a
good energy like old New York playing
the piano in there and stuff I just
[__] like I feel like I'm
I feel like I'm in a [__] Noir or
something I love it damn I want a slice
of pizza
oh you do you not eat pizza anymore I'm
laying off the Za that's good do you
look [__] good thanks that's amazing
man I'm really fishing the watch I know
right well you look [__] you look
good man I'm happy I'm happy you know
thanks Val you're [__] you're doing
well we want it we want to keep you
around thank you buddy buddy you and me
both
we finally get successful and he gets
the fact
that's when it happens I know yeah hey
trust me me too
I get it uh all right let's do uh let's
do one or two more here this one's just
funny this is from rwm uh are you
garbage if you bet on the Little League
World Series
Batman that's [__] crazy but if you
like action you like action they're
televising it and it's open game to me
they're not doing that on like the the
uh the sports book sites right that's
probably going to a bookie I don't think
I don't think DraftKings is
miners just drunks getting mad at
children you were supposed to [__]
hit a home run here I got a nickel on a
high school volleyball game I will say
this my friend text me a while like
years ago that he's like the [__] he
he lost a lot of money on like the
Minnesota Lynx and I was like you're
betting on [__] WNBA I remember being
like wow that's like a [__] you're
even gambling
uh but no I think whatever I you know I
anything especially if your kids are
playing in a [__] game line and make
it a little fun oh you're yeah bet
against them yeah well either way you're
a winner right you're happy pulling
their Gatorade
action nothing ain't nothing to cry
about Timmy dinners on me tonight A
Little League World Series man everybody
really gets behind that one that's a
perfect time in the summer everybody
loves it moms love it dads love it
everybody loves it I love it I love the
sound of the bat oh there's a woman
yeah I love it no the pros pro baseball
it's gotten a little better this year
but I'm a Yankees fan they [__] suck
but uh
man baseball just fell off I love it the
older I get the more I love it I still I
love this Philly's team I really do yeah
well I it's just uh they just [__] up
the MLB man like they just were so
averse to any social media they need
Toby to work for [__] baseball
he's not for sale I also hate baseball
it's the worst sport online really
terrible I love it I loved it in the 90s
so much and you like skateboarding and
stealing stuff from 7-Eleven don't
listen to him oh the two coolest things
you could do that's pretty good uh will
you go to a game have you been to a
Yankees game not in a while I haven't
been in this year he's a hoops man I
don't like I don't like the commute yeah
I went to a liberty game with Steve
recently and I did just see that it was
fun as hell man we had a great time uh I
like I love live basketball I love uh
are you only front row at the Garden
from now on is that how we're doing it
no I mean I'll truly [__] take it but
uh no dude I'll sit in the [__]
nosebleed so I don't give a [__] I'm
gonna I mean you're doing the [__]
goddamn theater they can't get you they
can't juice you with a couple of goods
it's always nice to see a pic of Sam
Morrell [__] sit in Courtside I'll
tell you that makes me feel like it yeah
it warms my heart man yeah I was sitting
next to the for doing one of the playoff
games it was like uh next to the Jonas
brothers were on one side of Me John
Starks was on the other damn I'm high
five in Starks in between plays I'm like
this is [__] I'm trying not to come
this is crazy I love John Starks now can
I ask you did you throw down for those
tickets or is that no they they hooked
that up but but uh what would that have
run yet I can't imagine a playoff game
probably 20. probably something crazy
yeah but uh I I love
I love live sports my thing with I love
football but I love watching football at
home I don't 100 I can't talk you miss
everything not only that but like
I don't like bad drunks I'm done with
bad I don't like being around I don't
like being stuck with bad drunks and
these people are [__] they're having
like seven beers in the parking lot
before the game like what's wrong with
that and now nothing but I don't I don't
football they're looking to fight that's
right it's around eclipse of like these
[__] this woman the Bengals fan oh
yeah but the women are fighting in ways
I'm like I don't fight like that that's
crazy like they are they're doing [__]
with their like [__] I'm like this is
like the dad's got beat up in front of
their kids that's always kill me I know
and like the dad's just getting knocked
the [__] out and the kids freaking out
it's like dude what are you you're not
supposed to realize you're dead so
[__] [__] until you're older yeah
that's when you're supposed to know
first of all you shouldn't be wearing a
jersey at [__] 45 and you're there
with your kid and then some [__] dude
knocks you the [__] out that therapy
Bill's gonna be pricey that's rough yeah
but I I do there's like certain things I
do kind of want to go to a Bills game at
some point in my life
I've seen a spectacle in person I love
it I know it's gonna be insanity but I I
kind of like I'm a Giants fan but I kind
of like Bills fans because they're so
[__] crazy yeah but uh I mean could
it be a worse start to the [__]
season with Aaron Rodgers I'm a Giants
fan but that was the worst [__] that was
like that was like almost funny how bad
it was yeah it's like the worst that was
like it was out of a movie of like all
right here it is and then [__] four
snaps and then that if it was something
dumb and he's back in two weeks three
weeks all right whatever but man that's
and the fact that he said sorry kid I'm
like this what is this the [__] end
of Tombstone this is brutal
poor bastard for me Zach I was just so
mean
when you're when you're sitting
Courtside are you chirping yeah you are
I got I'm shocked I didn't get in
trouble once because I was at a person
wait you're running your mouth to the
players
uh more it's more encouraging I'm more
like going next but I'll tell you years
ago I was Courtside for a preseason game
and uh God I was loaded I just kept
drinking and uh John Wall on the wizard
I feel bad about this I'm gonna go I
probably shouldn't even say this because
it's so stupid I did it but he came off
an Achilles injury and I [__] hated
the Wizards I just always kind of they
always bugged me and I just kept yelling
you've gained a lot of weight and and he
looked at me at one point and was just
like
and then years later he went High School
Mean Girls he was just like I was like
you've gained a significant amount of
weight John and he was like he's heard
me and I was like oh [__] I'm not used
to being this close yeah I'm used to
saying the [__] and knowing the people
around laughs yeah like he's crazy and
looked at me and I was like oh [__] and
then years later he was like I've
struggled with depression I was like I
hate myself
I suck I I felt bad I developed an
eating disorder yeah I was like I'm not
even hitting him with witty lines I was
at that level of drunk and uh yeah I
felt horrible something you would say to
your ex-girlfriend
I never really love you
John Stockton
[Applause]
but uh God damn man no damn yeah I I I
that one you kind of have to watch a
little because you're like these are
[__] people and it's right there it's
gotten to a point too like Russell
Westbrook
I love him too he's my [__] favorite
I just love it why are you talking [__]
to the guy that would [__] tattoo you
up and he's like one of the only players
in the league that I feel like may not
cheat on his wife like he's that [__]
loyal and yeah I just like kind of love
that dude yeah he's all right he's just
such a
takes a lot of heat too unfair heat yeah
but he uh
yeah he's just like my type of guy just
like a lot he's just a [__] Warrior I
love him
that's just not just my type
but no I mean not like that John Wall
real oinker if you know what I mean I
really let himself go
all right gang Mr Samuel theater at
Madison Square Garden November 4th I'm
all over the road all over the road
Chicago Theater September 30th I've got
a yeah stand up live in Phoenix October
5th through 7th I got Indianapolis
Cincinnati Columbus Cleveland Pittsburgh
uh all the end of October then we got
the big one at MSG we got uh we gotta oh
I'm going to Australia so all over
Australia in November I can't believe
I'm going man I'm [__] pumped and
then uh December we got like Vegas we
got uh at the win I got Tampa I'm going
back to Naples [__] Naples but I'm going
back and then yeah oh yeah no I forget
yeah that's a that's a that's an
Infamous one and then we got uh yeah and
then I'm adding a shitload of Club dates
because I'm gonna take my next special
in March so it's like crazy awesome
Philly so I gotta say shout out to
Philly every like all uh Irvine
everywhere [__] Oklahoma Springfield
Missouri like I'm going everywhere to
get this [__] airtight because I'm gonna
tape at the Wilbur in Boston in March
next special let's [__] go let's go
Sam Morel Kippy what do you got for him
we're also all over the road we're
adding a third show in Toronto get those
tickets uh Buffalo Pittsburgh which I
think is sold out I think we're adding a
fourth one in Chicago get those tickets
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee
Sacramento second show is almost sold
out San Francisco San Jose and the
second show at Philly in in Philly at
the Fillmore is more than halfway sold
out get those [__] tickets we love
you gang grab those ticket gangs we love
you and Sam just to say we love you yeah
true New Yorker true New York comedian
one of the absolute best ones I love you
guys man this is like the most fun
podcast there's like a few that I really
am pumped when you guys hit me up and
I'm like oh this is one of them for sure
so thank you appreciate that way [__]
dude the glue
no truly you're not wrong Toby like no I
knew it's funny when Toby was like I'm
doing I'm doing I'm like oh I know that
before it even started I know this pod
is going to blow up because this dude's
so [__] good it's great look at that
T-Bone we're gonna cut that part but
yeah you owe me 200 bucks by the way
do I really okay oh my God no I was like
we just invited you to Shake You Down
that's a well these aren't even on oh my
God that's like my biggest fear is like
forgetting to pay someone or something I
just did it two weeks ago to him yeah
what do you mean I just did it to him
yesterday but I did I did it to one of
our other editors I remember I opened
for a big comic once and he owed me
money and I was like God I don't want to
hit him up now you can't but it bummed
me out you can't hurt me money I was
like but uh you just gotta eat it yeah
you gotta eat it but uh because if you
say something you'll never work with him
again and I never did either
a cheap date a couple years later I was
like man I should have said something
I didn't do it on purpose I was kind of
like whatever well it happened today
especially when those dudes get bigger
it's like other people are paying the
bills it's like they don't know they're
just going yeah I assume everything got
paid because I'm focused on the next
thing I know but that's like my big
Toby's cut a bunch of videos for me in
the past I'm like holy [__] do I
actually owe him money yeah you should
have just said yes
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week peace peace